[Music]
okay boys and girls we're back with
the rematch the hammer
the also known as the 2 000
something california whatever champion i
don't know uh
it's gonna try again against me
we'll see what happens good luck but
this time i'm gonna play slower and
better
i'm just warning you ahead well faster
and better will be
would be even better but who knows
[Music]
i'll take it queen's gambit this is what
the kids do right
[Music]
i don't know anything about this i was
actually interested
i suppose really she's playing so
fast is he playing well this i do not
know
going for the pawn
[Music]
once again so accurately
again that was almost touch move wow
talking too much playing too little
you're still losing mr hammer you
are still completely busted here
unfortunately for you
[Music]
well iron i believe
has shown that speed is the main
ingredient
for this cocktail we have here between
these two people
oh
[Music]
i'm gonna get myself another one of
these pretty soon
[Music]
and i so much time so much time
it's embarrassing you can't do that oh
here's
[Music]
yeah my not a great game but who cares i
won